my name is chris norland
and i survived a plane crash as a baby
i was born at the end of the vietnam war
i don't have a birthday so i don't
really know
exactly when i was born americans know
that there were 56 000
gi deaths in the war but what the
americans don't talk about is there as
many as 3 million vietnamese killed in
the war
as a result of that there was as many as
a million orphans and i was one of them
the only paperwork that i had was a
little three by five card
that said the name of my orphanage so i
always knew it was sanctuary orphanage
in saigon
and there were three names on the card
however because i don't speak vietnamese
i
never really knew what the names meant
later in life i was able to
contact one of the nuns in my orphanage
she told me that 90
of the children died in my orphanage so
i'm really lucky to be alive
because it was at the end of the war
there was enough food
water and in fact we didn't even have
enough diapers so
they put us in buckets for most of the
day the one thing that the nurse told me
was that every orphan was loved in the
orphanage and it's something i always
remember that she told me
after president nixon resigned the north
vietnamese decided to attack
and take over the entire country and the
americans weren't going to fight anymore
essentially the war was over from the
americans perspective it was now
president ford
and he asked the american congress to
get money for what's called
operation baby lift operation baby lift
was a series of airlifts
in april 1975. it brought 3 300
vietnamese orphaned children to
countries like the usa
australia canada and france although the
official number says
3 300 children no one knows for sure
exactly how many children were evacuated
this was evacuation the end of the war
so it was very
chaotic for whatever reason i was put on
the first plane out it was a c5a
galaxy which at the time was the largest
airplane in the world the really big
cargo planes the one you see in the
movies the one you can
drive a jeep on into because i was a
baby they put me in a shoe box
and they put that on the airplane
passenger seat seat belted us
in our plane took off from townsend
airport there were over 300 people on
the plane
about 280 passengers and 30 crew members
after a few minutes in the air there was
a malfunction on the plane
and the rear cargo doors blew and all
the people in the lower half of the
plane just felt at a death
because i was young i was in the upper
half of the plane and therefore i
survived
after we lost power the pilots tried to
regain control
and so they ended up speeding up the
plane
and they turned around and
crashed into a rice field the plane
skidded for about a quarter of a mile
and then skipped up back in the air and
then crashed into a dike
we were full of fuel and the explain
exploded into four parts
and everything caught on fire the plane
was about a mile from the road
so when the americans said in the rescue
jeeps they had to
walk really far across the rice field
and
the helicopters arrived but they
couldn't land and so they would hover
above us
there was a smoke and fire everywhere
they would lower one rescue worker at a
time rescue one person and bring him
back up in a basket
but because the rescue operation was
slow some people actually survived
the crash but either burned to death or
drowned in the mud
about 176 people survived the crash
and about 138 children and
crew members were lost those of us that
survived the crash were flown to united
states
this crash was the largest loss of life
in defense intelligence agency history
until 9 11.
[Music]
when i arrived in the usa even though i
was here i still didn't have a country
south vietnam didn't exist anymore and
the americans didn't make me a citizen
i didn't have any paperwork so it was
actually really difficult
to prove that i existed all i had was my
little three by five card that said i
was from sancta murray orphanage
after living seven years in the usa and
i actually don't even know how old i am
because i don't have a birthday
i was eligible though to apply for u.s
citizenship so i went down to the
courthouse
and i swore to be an american like all
the other immigrants i had to miss a day
of school
the next day at school my teacher said
what did you do and
i said i became an american and i
remember really clearly this
little girl walks to the front of the
room and reads me welcome to america's
speech
and every kid in my grade made me
welcome to america cards and crayon
you know statue of liberty and
immigrants on boats
this is what america is to me after the
events of 9 11 i joined the united
states navy to be a pilot
growing up in the usa people would
always tell me that i was lucky to be
here
and lucky to be alive and in my head the
way they make you feel is that
america is the best place in the world
and all the other countries are not any
good so i always felt like i was from a
bad place i felt like i was
from a place where americans got killed
vietnam was never a place that was
a good place when i was in the military
and i would meet
vietnam veterans they were actually my
flight surgeons and they would look at
my charts and they would see that i was
from saigon
and they'd always ask me about that and
i always felt shame because i didn't
know much about my country
the thing that they always tell me is
that vietnam's a really beautiful
country
you know for years everyone would always
ask me if i would want to go back
and things like that and just always
seem so far away
seemed like another world like many
people i was lucky enough to
find someone to get married to my wife
was a korean national and so
i actually flew back to korea to meet
the family and while i was in korea
we were actually close enough to go to
vietnam so my
you know then fiance now my wife we went
to vietnam for the very first time and i
just i fell in love
it was beautiful people looked like me
which i'd never
seen before when i arrived at the saigon
airport it was ten sun nut
which was the same airport that my plane
back in 1975 had left from
emotion was was really overwhelming and
the humidity
i knew i had to return home one of the
things about being in vietnam and being
in saigon that's different than being
usa is
everybody knows about the plane crash
and everyone knows about people like me
one of the things i wanted to do is see
if i could find my orphanage and so i
did some googling and things because i
knew the name of the orphanage and i
found the address
and as it turns out my orphanage was in
the same neighborhood
that i chose my apartment it was
different than what i had imagined
the place just felt like just felt like
there was love there
and i understand now when the nuns said
that they loved every one of us
and i felt that when i was there you
know people always ask me if i want to
find my parents or from my family and
it's
come to accept that i don't have anyone
when i discovered the location of my
orphanage
there was a little bit of hope that
maybe i could find my parents or
something
and you know i had read stories and and
things where
you know sometimes these places have
like a book where they have all the
records and
you know we get to the orphanage and we
find out the orphans closed and
there was no office anymore and there's
no book and
just kind of accept that you know maybe
i'll never know emotionally in 2019 was
was a really
high for me 2020 though comes and
my wife is a korean national and the
immigration office was closed last year
so i returned to the usa
to try to facilitate my wife's green
card i haven't seen my wife since
december 2019
this year in 2020 i just do everything i
can to
spread positivity i started a podcast
called blue or sky
and the idea is that not only is
tomorrow going to be
a blue sky day something positive it's
going to be bluer
than you could ever imagine because of
where i came from
and because of the way i grew up i never
looked down on anyone and i never make
fun of anyone because i know
that a lot of good people in the world
can come from any background because i
don't have any family
i find myself reaching out to people all
the time to develop relationships
and share as many positive messages as i
can
because i feel that we can rely on each
other
and support each other through these
tough times
[Music]
you